auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge
[Musik]
cornelia breit schmiede und schon marie
suter waren den großen schritt sie
wandern nach marokko aus
neues leben neues glück die familie
händler übernimmt den schwedisch
lappland eine hotel und campinganlage
und auf und davon in ein neues abenteuer
mit kamelen zieht die familie blum durch
das australische outback
[Musik]
helle aufregung wegen der nordlichter in
schwedisch lappland
im spätherbst wenn die nächte länger und
länger werden beginnt die saison der
nordlichter
mit zwei helfern seiner lodge macht sich
max händler auf das naturschauspiel zu
fotografieren
das heißt wir nicht
längst ist das
problem dagegen aber der tank ist
morgens
nicht erwarten dass ich so berühmt dass
geht die energie fürs eingetroffen
in der letzten folge hatte der ältere
sohn der händler seinen ersten ski tag
gold wird auch kimi das kinderhaus
besuchen und jasmin so mehr luft
verschaffen
[Musik]
denn bisher war es max allein der das
geschäft vorangetrieben hat 100 meter
terrasse das hat hier sonst niemand eine
riesige villa ist ihr neues daheim doch
noch ist cornelia breitschmid und schon
marie suter die marokkanische kultur
fremd
[Musik]
ein stück heimat in der fremde brachte
die ankunft von maries pfeifen werkstatt
seit wochen ist die familie blumen im
australischen outback unterwegs
jeder tag neue überraschungen
[Musik]
in schweden ist es herbst geworden die
sommergäste sind mit ihren wohnmobilen
wieder nach hause gerollt
du wirst dich
die urlauber sind zwar weg aber max
henzler bewirtet auch viele gäste aus
der region
jede jahreszeit hat ihre schönen seiten
wenn es kalt ist lockt ein bad im heißen
zugang dem brandneuen hot ab
[Musik]
die erste sommersaison im leben der
ferien lodge betreiber ist zu ende max
ist nicht ganz glücklich jetzt gar nicht
besser aber de facto sind also man zum
zielgruppen sind sechs bezahlte um ist
in 25 prozent bevor die auch wenn man
sich eine folie oder scheiben mit dem
was sie vorgang scharf gemacht und
relativ viel in die reparatur überhaupt
zusammen
[Musik]
dazu
dass es noch
soeben gesagt seit kurzem kümmert sich
jasmin um die buchhaltung jetzt wo beide
buben das kinderhaus besuchen kann sie
endlich auch für das geschäft da sein
es war eine anstrengende saison nun
heißt es die anlage winterfest zu machen
bevor der erste schnee fällt versorgt
die familie alles im kopf
dass jasmin und max gemeinsam anpacken
das gab es in den letzten monaten kaum
weitab der heimat eine neue existenz
aufzubauen hat dem ehepaar viel
abverlangt
wie hoch der preis dafür ist das wissen
sie an diesem herbsttag noch nicht
[Musik]
im australischen outback lebt die
familie blum seit wochen in harmonie mit
der natur
links
und sie halten es wie die eidechsen mit
den ersten sonnenstrahlen stehen sie
auch
ja
kein lehrer kein unterricht während
dreier monate ist es das einfache leben
welches amira und neuere schult
mit und sie lernen sich unterhalten ohne
irgend etwas
fantasie wie es gefördert mein gestiegen
spiels mit nägel büchsen und holz mal so
mal so
es ist die welt der blues ist in ordnung
fast jedenfalls
[Musik]
in der altstadt von elvira
immer wieder lassen sich cornelia und
schon marie vom zauber der medina
verführen heute wollen sie ihre
maßgeschneiderten bezüge abholen doch
zuerst tee trinken
tee gehört in marokko einfach dazu
die awards sind angekommen
[Applaus]
problem
so kompliziert sind und nicht gott aber
sehr positiv bestätigt
aber dass meine trost konnte so viel ich
mein
geschäft jetzt genau
es läuft dann
auf den tee folgt der handel der findet
abseits der einkaufsstraße statt
[Musik]
nein
ein schneider hat für die auswanderer
über 40 kisten und matratzenbezüge
genäht
[Musik]
das liegt
lassen wir
[Musik]
sämtliche kissen und matratzen ihres
großzügigen salons kriegen ein neues
kleid haus setze mal der das
ist eine dufte nein die könig boris
capla stick mehr gebraucht werden in
eine marokkanische stube gehört auch das
bild des königs
und problemen her dass ich mich dass er
alaba six fällig
das
dauerhafte stoff herzlich ein bisschen
ich war ist schon
das überzeugt mich nun also das lied es
gottes auseinander
es ist also eine 10 exakt
[Musik]
leise hat sich der schnee über
nordschweden gelegt
der sensible familienhund brian leidet
nicht wegen des schnees sondern wegen
seines clans
[Musik]
vor 14 jahren wurden jasmin und max ein
paar
in den letzten monaten haben sie sich
immer mehr entfremdet
nun ist das passiert was sich niemand
gewünscht oder je gedacht hätte
ja es ist
eine ganz
schwierige situation sie
ganz ganz so methoden
verlassen gefühlt
ausgestanden
ist für anderes schweiz
[Musik]
das ist scheiße dortmund klar mein name
ist in der luft kommt ich bin voll
aufgegangen will
sich versehentlich der honig
vermittler man ist
einfach fakt ist
jede
person spielt
dieses
das hat sich entschied das ist ist rocco
ist hat sich jetzt bis bedeckt und das
ist yanofsky dass das man merkt an dass
gott nicht wachrütteln und die
spielkarte die personen
[Musik]
die diakonie schicksals oder
so stritt über
losgesagt
ich wollte hier ein who's mitbringt und
erwin staiger
[Musik]
und als beruf gebe es einfach nicht
kommen will der verlust größer
und ich sage mit zwei kind und nun
laufen konnte und selbst aber
wirklich wenig sie
nämlich dass hier eine beschlossen
peters
wir sind ja bekannt dass die hand ist
alles drin gesteckt was mir hand wieder
momentan geschädigten was mache ich von
bank sieht
das werde so bleiben wie es jetzt gut
ist
trotz des schmerzes keiner der beiden
ist der folge hand zwischen jasmin und
max herrscht nun eine art burgfrieden
b
es ist jasmin die bestimmt ob und wann
merkst dass große familien haus betreten
den umgang miteinander müssen die beiden
erst wieder finden
hühner katzen und schildkröten haben bei
den aargauer auswanderung ein neues
zuhause gefunden
bald soll ihr heim auch hort für
feriengäste sein
cornelia checkt die preise anderer
gasthäuser
[Musik]
dieses buch ein technisch
orientierter frank zimmer mit dem
doch zuerst steht ein familienbesuch in
maries tochter und enkelsohn
mit fast 50 jahren hat cornelia ihr
leben komplett umgekrempelt
früher stand die juristin dem
sozialdienst des kantons aargau vor und
führte 140
mitarbeitenden
auch
nicht langweilig das auto aber überhaupt
nicht
und
es ist ja nicht so dass man immer
[Musik]
die gästehäuser werden derzeit renoviert
geht es hat es nun genug platz
[Musik]
wie jean marie seine ruhe haben verzieht
er sich in seine pfeife werkstatt
jahrelang hatte der frühpensionär bei
der asylbehörde gearbeitet nun baut der
pfeifen im norden afrikas
schöne stück und vor dem her bin ich
schon ein richtiger land nummer nach
daniel es gibt vielleicht ironie
verbracht und danke wohin jetzt amtlich
berater und mache da bin ich eigentlich
ja einfach sofort kaufen die haben vor
der heimat
protestiert wurde aber
mittlerweile habe ich merke dass es
selber nicht wichtig für europa nicht
schnell da und
handwerker
fertig und ich merke wie kind gern
daheim
nachtmann gesehen ich hatte bloß
[Musik]
kein internet keine ipads keine youtube
filmchen im outback spielt die familie
blumen karten
[Musik]
und beruf statt das mit alles für seine
kunst noch
mit wasser müssen die blues
haushälterisch umgehen je nachdem wie
vor ihre tanks sind heute konnten sie
wasser auffüllen heute gibt es ein bad
[Musik]
richtig
das grand fragen gefallen lassen das ist
so ist man dass die halt daneben sowie
zwei
und und da sowieso da hat es war
sozusagen etwas einfach noch mal eine
andere politik
darum wird sich amira ins selbe
badewasser setzen
sie wisse
was war passiert ist
die daumen drehen trinkt
[Musik]
wegen des geschäfts aber noch mehr wegen
der kinder versuchen die henzlers zu
funktionieren
eine art normalität aufrechtzuerhalten
am frühen morgen bringt max die kinder
ins kinderhaus dort sind krippe und
kindergarten unter einem dach
und auch die mama die zur schule
[Musik]
jasmin ist eine kämpferin sie gibt nicht
so schnell auf
entschlossen hat sie ihr schicksal in
die hand genommen seit kurzem besucht
sie an drei vormittagen einen
spanischkurs
abstellen das noch offen ist für
versprach das ist schon so dass man
einfach
safran chile
will dass ich das mit meinen kontakten
kommt mittlerweile schwer
gestört wurde also ich sag mal
verwundert sind ihr 5 hannover
und das ist
jetzt nicht da konnte ich hier bin ich
nur
das ist natürlich im es geschafft das
bistum bin ich einem den erweiterungs
gesetzt und
er holt aus
[Musik]
mit sonder entscheidung das brutale sich
gezogenen scheiding bringt drei raus ist
im
schlussspurt der aufruf lewis sind und
sich auf fremden
ins auto funktioniert wird muss möglich
sein
er brütet sprach sieht man kennt sich
und lenkt ist ist schaaf die netze um
das kann man sehr sehr gut vorstellen
das funktioniert
funktioniert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mindestens zweimal pro woche packt
sabrina ein punkt im topf das kann
dauern
es sind solche momente des friedens und
der verbundenheit die die familie
glücklich machen
sie geschäfte sollen hier mit michael
stoltz politik bis 2020
die armee des
sonder und helfer kommen mit dem anfangs
im ruhm und haben
jetzt gleicht er habe nur mit dem motto
aus minden sich das mal
ist es glaube ich wirklich ist privileg
also ich meinen job und kind schlafen
und
kind werden so schnell groß und älter
und und das hier jetzt so viel zeit mit
ihnen verbringen
und das macht mir unheimlich stolz dass
mir geschehen aber nicht mit krieg sie
im dreck spielen wenn ich sehe wie 30
grad bar vor sommer laufen und und dem
dreck spielen und und meinte mir aber
nach runden und konzerns für das macht
mich stolz
jetzt sind
doch gut ding will weile haben noch ist
das brot nicht perfekt
natalie zeit ja wir sind da stunde lang
im winter kamele
geworden
die macht sich lang richtig endlich
erleichtern so als müsste ihm dadurch
fahrer und sind 1000 us geologen und wir
bauen und das
meine ich schwöre ich dann dass es
ist ein innerer schlussendlich
sind im heft und seinem buch folge und
ich meine man muss man etwas machen
jetzt nicht denken dass momentan gar
nicht mehr vorstellen
ich muss mich bei immer
schlimmer
naja
durch das einfache die größe des lebens
erfahren das ist es was die blumes ihren
kindern mitgeben wollen
noch ist ihre entdeckungsreise nicht zu
ende noch warten einige hundert
kilometer wüstenlandschaft bevor die
blumes zurück nach davos müssen
[Musik]
so marie hat sich einen herzenswunsch
erfüllt einen eigenen esel schon in der
schweiz hatte er ysl besessen
[Musik]
es ist eine eselin und sie heißt aber
unterschlupf hat aber beim gärtner der
aargauer gefunden
[Gelächter]
kommenden sonntag wird mein enkelsohn
aaron aufarbeiten
einen geraden rücken und einen guten
charakter hat die salinen damit auch
kinder gefahrlos auf ihr reiten können
[Musik]
die anrufe aber ich muss nach lienz ist
kann ich nicht
okay
aber
damit rasch
[Musik]
ja
und so wagt cornelia den ersten diesel
schritt ihres lebens wohl auch weil sie
weiß dass jean marie vertrauen kann
aber man kann es jetzt mehr so anwander
arbeiter das vertrauen gerade eine
entscheidung haben wann der eisbär im
chart verschossen
aber es
[Musik]
nachmittags um drei in nordschweden ist
es schon seit einer halben stunde dunkel
gemeinsam haben die henzlers die bogen
im kinderhaus von owatonna abgeholt
[Musik]
jetzt während des winters wo es ihnen
denn noch hier in lodz ruhiger ist jetzt
könnte die familie eigentlich
zusammenrücken
[Musik]
auch wenn max die trennung schmerzt
gegen aussen versucht er ein guter
gastgeber zu sein
heißt rodó
trotzdem hat sich strom und der blog
schönes garten ist schon
[Musik]
etliche möglichkeiten fantastische
zwischen dieses und ertragen kann das
kann man
den kollegen freunde das sich an die
manche kam es für kultur kamen zwei
zwischen
meinestadt.de sich
als künstler geprägt und mir das wie
trainer birgit
und du
bist das emotional und akzeptieren sie
bietet contest finden ist
tiefes zeigen
[Musik]
ibiza eine trennung während sich die
kinder in eine völlig neue umgebung
einleben müssen der zeitpunkt könnte
schlechter nicht sein die pläne sind es
warten kann es bedient was mehr als
ältere
land funktioniert
losfahren das rasieren will wenn wir
jetzt da wir machen funktioniert dem dem
wenig gewundert
[Applaus]
den hengst steht keine einfache zeit
bevor da hilft der sensible familien und
brian als ruhender pol
[Musik]
jasmin und max wollen und müssen und
weiter machen
und manchmal liegt auch hier müssen eine
große chance denn nur wer nicht aufgibt
kann gewinnen
[Musik]
die familie blum ist zurück ein kaufen
im bioladen ist wieder normalität
vor vier wochen haben die blums die
kamele und den planwagen abgegeben und
sind nach hause in die schweiz
zurückgekehrt
amira fand in ihrer alten klasse wieder
anschluss meurer besucht neu den
kindergarten
auch neuerer hat aus down under einen
schatz mitgebracht
markus arbeitet wieder auf dem baum
[Musik]
und auch die eltern haben viele
erinnerungen in die schweiz mitgenommen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da ist noch eine klage des landes
sie haben mich
perfekt der filmmaterial noch
die blues hoffen mit vorträgen einen
teil ihrer nächsten reise finanzieren zu
können
man wundere einfach
groß und immer größer einfach immer
wieder neues und anderes zu entdecken
und man jetzt ganz
allein
sibirien
die abenteuer los der blums scheint noch
lange nicht gestillt zu sein
[Musik]
auf und davon das ist ihr lebensmotto
[Gelächter]
jetzt sind sie da damaris tochter und
enkel armen der angehende hieß es weiter
als erstes macht amon bekanntschaft mit
einer kröte
[Gelächter]
trotz kröte tochter sarah nicht
begeistert
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sich natürlich nehmen so oft wie
wenn man es ein paar kilometer
voneinander weg war aber um so
unwahrscheinlich weil man sich einig
hälfte fertig sind jetzt schon mal taxi
und die andere hälfte
acht kinder und bis jetzt acht enkel hat
schon marie suter
weder als großeltern noch als gastgeber
werden cornelia und show marie die
aufgaben ausgehen
[Musik]
warum
sie den hessen
schon dass das
hinter sind erinnerung geblieben
erinnert mini großmutter das ist aber
ein paradies
und wann war
minimal
zu danken und zu uns kurzerhand
[Musik]
und völlig konnte mit
ich hab so und da kann ich dann mal mit
paar
[Musik]
wünsche
die auswanderung der aargauer verlief
anders als geplant nach vielen umwegen
haben sie aber das wichtigste erreicht
ein heim zum wohlfühlen für sich die
familie und bald auch für gäste
kurz vor der ausstrahlung dieser letzten
folge erreicht er uns aus schweden eine
erfreuliche botschaft
max zog wieder ins familienhaus 1 nach
langen gesprächen haben sich jasmin und
max wieder gefunden und
sie hätten es so gut wie schon lange
nicht mehr lassen sie ausrichten
[Musik]
die muss ich die gerne mit dabei kommen
viele die aus gehen auch sie auf und
davon dann melden sie sich unter
auswandern 11.10 wir suchen spannende
geschichten von auswandern
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge